Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Byrd is time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 22nd,
2016 what's going on?
How I,
how's it going?
Happy Monday to enrich and every one of you I was going to say to every one of
you,
then I decided to throw in each.
So that's why the each sounded weird.
They're just election now.
Um,
it's another beautiful day out here in Los Angeles,
uh,
getting ready to go out to fox woods.
Um,
this,
uh,
this weekend,
right?
Yeah.
Friday I'll be in New York City and then a Saturday and Sunday I'm going to be
at Foxwoods and um,
it's going to be hopefully going to be a good time.
I'm going to do a bunch of standup this week so I'm not rusty old freckles.
Can't be walking in there rusty.
And I'm definitely looking forward to getting back there,
although I heard it's fucking freezing.
Um,
but whatever,
you know,
I could visit winter.
I'm a big fucking southern California softy now.
They get there,
my teeth chatter and when it gets in the forties,
it's actually not true.
And that shit too,
where they go,
your blood thins out,
your know your blood thirds out.
Then you go back,
you can't handle the cold.
It's like,
no,
that's not what happens.
You,
you're,
you have access to information in a beautiful life that you could be living
still within the parameters of this great country.
You know,
all you people back this shoveling,
that wet snob,
just letting you need,
you don't have to do it.
You know,
I took my dog out this morning do about,
oh,
do you know what I had on?
I had on a wind break
just walking down the street.
I could sit on my back porch in the sun right now.
Okay.
And burn another couple of cancer causing freckles into the top of my head.
Well,
I had a little bit of corn flakes,
you know,
sitting out there like the Douche in the goal.
Great nut commercials.
Zoe's some guy,
right?
He come out,
it was like he was a man's man,
but a pretty boy.
You know,
like Tom Brady,
except he couldn't throw a football,
that guy.
Right?
And he'd come out with the,
the impossible.
Impossibly white robe,
brand new white robe.
They even fucking bleed suit,
right.
The widest shit ever.
And He,
you know,
he's got a little fucking bullet grape nuts.
Always had some fruit in there cause he had that kind of time.
Sky was so successful.
He had the time to cut up fruit and do is fucking great nuts.
He'd go out on his back porch and just chill.
I remember as a,
as a little boy,
as a little orange headed fucking freckled pussy.
I remember watching that just go and like that guy say,
guys live in a life looking at,
look how,
look how white that robust,
it's got fruit in his fucking grape nuts.
This guy's crushing it.
Is He fucking come on,
I want to,
I want to see the rest of his life.
Let me see as loud.
And that was the genius of that commercial.
They never showed his Brian.
I don't think they did.
Maybe she came out afterwards.
You know,
I don't think so.
But that's the genius of it.
It left you wanting more and you started thinking about his life and he started
thinking,
you know what,
you don't Vice Dodi Greg much.
Maybe I'll have an impossibly white robe and I'll come out and I'll actually
have pigment my skin,
you know,
nice full head of hair and I'll walk out on my deck barefoot,
look,
I like,
I got all the money in the world,
I got all the answers,
confidence,
hell and I even have time to cut up fruit,
my cereal.
I want that life,
you know?
And here it is years later to this day,
you know,
I'm still eating great much.
Sure.
I never got the pigment bay.
I lost the hair,
had some structural damage to my house shell,
but I have tried to cut up some fruit.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
yeah,
so your blood doesn't fit out.
Yeah,
it doesn't then out.
You just know what it's like to experience an 85 degree day in fucking February
and then you go back,
you just like what the,
you know what it's like.
It's like you ever see a rich person have to stand in line.
It's the combination of frustration and confusion.
It's more confusion and frustration.
It's more like,
wait,
I,
I don't wait.
I got money.
Like okay here,
who wants this?
Who do I give this to so I can go around this.
I don't want to be with these animals.
These are the people that make my dreams come true.
They show up at my factory.
All right.
They put the fucking,
the nut and bolt and the widget
that I bought off of somebody else,
they came in with the design.
They didn't have any money.
I made him sign a piece of paper.
I on the patent to their idea.
I go around all this,
right,
rich guy thoughts and the ditches,
that confusion.
It's like w w,
w why am I,
I don't do this anymore.
That's what West Coast people who've lived on the east coast.
Then when they go back east,
you know what we paratroop into fucking winner.
That's,
that's what would think like I don't do this anymore.
He's chap faced fucking animals back here.
I'm a fucking doing the shoveling wet snow,
stretching out your back,
you know,
all excited cause you got a new snow blower,
you know that's your winner.
That's for you.
I go around that man.
I don't do that shit.
I'm out of my back porch.
Yeah,
basketball be too great much.
It's how I'm doing it.
Do My fucking dog is laying on his bed right now.
Okay.
It's like from the neck down,
it's on the bed and then like it's head is hanging off of the bed onto the
hardwood floor.
I mean it looks literally like it got hit by a tranquilizer.
All right.
And you know what I did with what?
The dog today.
This is why she's so exhausted after at least 11 hours sleep last night.
The fucking thing goes to bed at like seven at night.
It's hilarious.
Like whenever I'm watching the game and I'm just sitting there,
she's like over in the corner,
just curled up in a ball,
sound asleep.
Okay.
Which is why now for,
I can't get her off this clock here.
She keeps,
I don't know how to keep her up,
you know,
cause she keeps waking me up at like five 30 quarter to six in the morning.
It's driving me nuts.
So anyways,
so now after 11 hours of sleeping,
I,
all I did was I took it around the block,
that city she looks at,
she ran a marathon.
I don't fucking know.
I don't understand why they're so goddamn sleepy all the time.
I've never,
I mean,
I've had dogs my whole life.
I've never seen a dog sleep the way this fucking thing sleeps.
Then it gets up at five 30 in the morning,
like a goddamn drill sergeant.
The only thing it's missing is,
you know,
remembered full metal jacket when the guy came walking in and he was beating the
Billy club against the empty trashcan.
That's basically what she does to me every morning,
except it's way more adorable.
I'll be like sound asleep and then I'm walking up to a cold nose doing that dead
fucking psycho way.
They sniff it does,
that shit is fucking her paintbrush.
Tunc and I'm like Blah.
That's how I wake up every morning and I'm one of those people,
once you wake me up,
it's fucking over.
All right.
Just just to let you know,
kiss you ever sleeping next to me,
you know,
keep it quiet.
Um,
all right,
let's move on.
Um,
as I mentioned on the Thursday afternoon podcast just before Friday,
um,
other,
I was going to the,
uh,
the warriors game.
Um,
I was going to the warriors
game and I was taking the lovely Nia and uh,
cause I wanted to go see Steph curry in his prime.
You know,
you got to see them when they're young for they get the first major injury or
before they just get old and remind you that you're going to die someday.
You know,
you don't need to see that.
But doing that,
you know,
I saw Michael Jordan back when he had hair.
I see him early.
All right.
When he was still skinny and the Pistons were beating the shit out of him and he
was dropping 60 on the Celtics,
I saw him then.
He was probably,
I saw him when he was,
they would probably,
okay.
I think it was right before the Jordan three s came out.
It was probably the second pair,
by the way,
for the record,
when the first air of Air Jordans came on,
I thought they were the ugliest fucking things I'd ever seen in the,
in the red and black bulls colors.
I thought they were the ugliest fucking things I'd ever seen it by the way,
Celtics fans,
how much more likable is pog or Saul now that he's not on the Lakers.
I don't know what it is.
My hatred of the Lakers really just maybe hate that guy way more than I needed
to.
Um,
anyway,
so we go down to the game and um,
um,
yeah,
like ridiculous,
excited.
Like I'm seeing one of the great NBA teams of all time and I'm seeing arguably
the greatest shooter this early in his career.
You can actually make that argument.
This is,
this guy's the greatest shooter in Nba History and in my lifetime I've watched
Andrew,
Tony,
Larry Legend,
Reggie Miller,
and I even throw Coby Brian in there.
I never saw a guy have two people hanging on them out by the three point line
and just with his back to the fucking hope and he's still somehow gets it.
You know,
God knows he's not looking for the open man trying to beat the double team.
Why would you do that
anyways,
so I go there,
I get on stub hub,
right?
I fucking paid through the nose.
You know what I mean?
Fuck it.
Pay through the nose.
I get a six row behind,
uh,
not behind the bench but almost behind the warriors bench,
but whatever the fucking table,
what are the announcers are in?
Shit,
I'm,
I'm like somewhere in there,
six rows back.
And one of the great things is when you go to an NBA game is like if you six
rows deep,
you can like literally hear them calling for the ball.
You know,
if like if the coach curse Steve Curve,
he fucking cursed at the ref.
Like,
Oh,
what the fuck?
And he gets teed up.
I know what he said.
All right.
That's what I paid for.
That's why I went on stubhub and I said,
fuck it.
Huh?
You want to wheel Barb barrel full of cash?
Here you go.
I'm not fucking sitting all the way.
The staples center is the fucking worst.
You,
you got to sit down low or else it's like they got this brownstone of a
corporate boxes,
three deckers,
three,
three fucking levels of them all the way around.
It's like a moat between the fucking haves and the have nots.
And then all the real fans,
they're up by the fucking air condition ducts.
So it's like,
that's what the option is.
Either way the fuck up their pay through the nose.
So I said,
fuck it.
I'm going to pay through the nose,
right?
So,
and I'm going to get there.
I'm going to hear him talk and I'm gonna Watch them.
One of the great shooters of all fucking time.
And I get that dude.
And I know during all of this,
I'm going to sound like a grumpy old man,
but what the fuck happened to,
to,
to go into an NBA game?
Two,
they didn't.
There wasn't one moment of silence the entire fucking,
they even play music when the fucking games going on.
I didn't hear one sneaker squeak.
I heard a couple of yo the call for the ball.
That was it.
I heard nothing because the entire fucking time that game's going on some
fucking Douche.
She's playing everybody clap your hedge,
tick,
tick.
The whole,
they played that fucking 50 fucking types.
First of all,
I walked into the fucking building,
right?
And I'm all excited.
Where's my seats?
I paid through the nose.
Here we go,
right?
It's like you go on vacation and use all your fucking miles was sitting up on
the front of the play.
You can't fucking wait to get on a plane.
Where's my big comfy fucking seek that I fucking pay for,
right?
That's the level of excitement I had and I go in there and I'm coming down to
the seats and first of all,
there's some DJ guy.
There's always a fucking Dj.
You can't even buy a pair of fucking pants.
Now you walk into a store,
there's a fucking some sad look at DJ there just shouldn't now you know with his
bad posture,
you know some hack Dj just fucking play in music.
I love to with like curse words in it too.
Like you were in like a place of business,
you know,
cause I'm fucking you to not right.
The plane like Biggie and shit.
Right.
So,
um,
anyways,
this is fucking Dj.
Okay.
And he's,
I don't know what the fuck he's doing.
Okay.
Every five seconds make so no
people at section 300 ready do go to Ebay.
Damn hasn't even started,
but the fuck are we cheering?
Yeah.
Huh?
Are you getting this hype for the game?
You fucking dope.
We're borrowing is.
See the clippers and the warriors.
The words got five losses.
This is like watching the 96 bowls,
the tear that they're on.
I don't need you and your Richie Cunningham Varsity fucking clippers jacket out
there screaming and fucking yelling.
Oh,
it gets worse.
I might blow a fucking buy them an aneurysm on this one.
So I'm walking down,
gone.
Oh my God.
How long has this guy got to be yelling at us?
Okay.
And meanwhile,
meanwhile,
by the way,
you know the clippers are out shooting around and the worries about ready to
take the court,
I'm going to get to watch Steph curry fucking hit like 18 three point in a rump.
You know,
that's what I want to see.
That's what I want to hear.
Okay.
I know need back.
So I don't need that shit.
Right.
But you know,
it's a new day.
It's a new generation.
Their time.
I'm just a grumpy old man,
right?
So I get down on my sheet that I paid through the fucking nose for right on the
fucking I'll,
and that what looks to be,
it looks like Steph Curry's mouth guard that he's constantly fucking chewing on,
right?
And it's like this bracelet and I didn't know what it was.
It looked like a fucking,
it looked like a one of those things.
They stick in the bottom of a men's urinal,
right?
Urinal cake.
Except he gets sticky a fucking,
you can put it on your wrist.
So it's taped to the back of my seat.
So I immediately just flipped the fucking thing over the other side of my seat.
Okay.
Immediately I'm not participating.
All right.
Total contrarian.
Canty fucking standup loaner comic.
I'm not being part of the group immediately.
Right.
And I'll take that.
I'll take 40% of the blame or the rest of this fucking wine and shit.
All right.
But the other 60% I'm fucking right.
So I fucking flip that thing over.
And the fucking Dj guy with the Richie Cunningham varsity clippers jacket is
down there and he's,
he's like,
everybody hold up you fucking a yard.
Okay.
And when you hold it up,
don't forget dog back.
So everybody clap your hands.
Tech Tech,
tech tech to do this is all going on,
right?
Insanity.
Oh,
and by the way,
there's a bunch of fucking,
you know,
okay.
Like I swear to God what's said,
who's that fucking guy who does the,
he sells the nice comfortable tee shirts,
but for some reason he shoots like 12 year old girls and like sexual positions.
The fuck is the name of that company.
It's not an Abercrombie and Fitch.
They were into like fucking,
wasn't it like a white supremacists,
Kennedy children?
I can't,
I,
you know,
they,
it all blends together.
It begins with an egg.
That's all I know.
So they got these fucking like preteens,
it looks like calm it down,
you know,
dress like prostitutes and fucking like a a B Hollywood movie.
Right.
You know,
like the ones in a pretty woman.
Yeah.
The only exciting part of that was when he was looking for a hooker and then he
runs into that fucking,
you know,
molar show and fucking champ there.
Right.
I always hate it when he fucking closed it shut.
She goes fucking laugh at all those fucking teeth.
Jesus Christ.
Uh,
I swear to God,
that clip right there is why I never dropped acid.
Cause if I ever ran into a woman like that,
and she did the,
I swear to God,
I've,
I don't know what happened.
I think my fucking head would explode.
So anyways,
Geez,
I haven't got to the start of the fucking game yet.
So much is fucking bugged me.
So dare doing dance routines,
all the shit.
So in the meantime,
the fucking warriors take the court and everybody bows him and everything,
and I'm just literally going like,
oh my God,
there he is.
There he goes,
here he goes,
and he starts hitting fucking threes.
And the second he does every fucking jerk off and the fucking building,
right?
Who was it making?
So this came running down the fucking aisle.
Everybody with their cell phone cameras out taking fucking video standing up in
front of me.
Here I am paying through the nose to my seat.
I have them in the six row.
I got to stand up to watch the shoot around.
What are you filming it for?
The fuck are you filming?
Okay.
Can't you just fucking just sit there and watch it?
I saw Larry Bird do a shoot around 1986 I still remember I got the video right
in my fucking head.
Just fucking dope.
All these fucking Yolo Douche.
She's come down right with their fucking phones.
So I'm just going,
Oh God,
here we go.
You know bill pay.
You know you're the old guy.
Now this is,
this is how the youngster do it.
This is how they fucking do it,
right?
So Mercer,
fleets,
people finally ended up sitting down.
It's the end of the goddamn shoot around and we're get ready to start the game,
right?
And I'm thinking like,
okay,
finally this fucking this,
this,
this seizure of shit of tumblers and who cheese it fucking screaming and yelling
and making noise and,
and bracelets.
Fucking blinking is going to end and I can watch the fucking game,
right?
There's no way this horse shit goes on
during the game.
There's no fucking way.
And evidently it's okay that they play music too.
The whole fucking thing.
I'm watching Steph curry bringing the ball up and I'm listening to Drake.
You'll use the Colby all myself off.
Gilgo dog yogurt though.
Everybody clap your hands back so fucking,
I can barely get to speak of squeaking,
dude.
The NBA used to be the greatest fucking game.
If you sat down low to see the game live,
there's,
there's no,
there's not like hockey where you behind the fucking glass,
you know,
it's almost like it's soundproof.
And even that's still amazing to be down that close.
But still there's like this barrier.
You fucking sit right down on the court and they're right there.
The fucking ball could bounce into your lap was insane.
And,
and you know,
look,
like I said,
I'll take 40% of this.
This is just me being a grumpy old man.
Okay?
You got to keep,
the game has to keep evolving.
These kids are growing up with Dj's.
People are asking them to make noise and they like to make noise.
This is what they're fucking generation does it fine,
fine,
but can,
can you just dial it back a little bit?
Okay.
Every time there was a time out,
all of a sudden there was all these fucking people run up it,
by the way,
the kids out there to have a kid dance team.
Can you have him do a fucking kid dance?
You know what I mean?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Half those fucking moves I've seen in a Teddy Barr and I'm a fucking looking at
an eight year off dude.
Okay.
Everybody clap your hands into the whole fucking thing was insane.
And,
um,
so anyways,
in what moves,
one of the funny things was I'm sitting there with Nia,
right?
And you know,
she's a great person.
She's not a grumpy person,
so she's just enjoying all of it.
She's taken it and she's enjoying the game,
you know?
And when all of a sudden they started like I swear to God in like little
parachutes stays dropdown,
um,
gift certificates to something that evidently we couldn't afford.
I don't know what it was like,
I can't even,
what the fuck it was.
Everybody's jumping up,
like leaping up trying to catch these things.
Like it's,
you know,
the end of the Vietnam War and this is a ticket to get on the last chopper out
of there.
Right?
Oh,
and then the fucking tee shirts,
all of this shit I hate when they sit there and they got one t shirt left and
they start looking at the section whatever section can make the most noise.
And just watching people like a fucking dog begging for a treat for a free
fucking clippers,
a clippers teach.
This isn't even a Lakers tee shirt.
This is a clippers tee.
Just watching all of those people taking all of this self esteem,
all every shred of integrity and jumping up and down over a fucking eight year
old to get a free tee shirt.
I don't know.
So anyways,
so nia points out,
there's some guys sitting in the front row that she follows on a
snapchat,
I believe it's called.
I keep calling it Instagram,
snapchat,
and he says,
dude,
it just goes,
Yo,
they don't want you to fucking blah,
blah,
blah.
And he's always doing whatever they say you can't do.
And she goes,
look at him.
He's down there,
he's right there.
Oh look,
he's making a snapchat video.
She's watching the guy make the snapchat video.
And then she takes out her cell phone in two seconds later she watches the
thing.
And I'm watching the guide down there and doing a snapchat.
I just watched the guy film,
but now I'm watching her,
her phone.
And by the way,
in the meantime,
Steph curry is going up and down the fire.
Everybody clap your hands,
right?
I got add.
I don't eat all of that shit.
Oh,
so anyways,
I zipped that isn't bad enough
as if I haven't been going on and on,
you know,
needing an entire fucking box of tampons at this point.
How much I'm bitching at least even though I can't hear it,
even though there's going to be somebody standing up in front of me,
even though there's shooting tee shirts at me telling me to make some noise and
clap my fucking hands like I don't know where I'm at.
Okay.
Helen Keller,
she'd get like this level of fucking direction.
If she goes out,
she's dead.
Whatever.
Anyways,
Steph curry,
Steph curry goes out there immediately gets a file.
I'll give a team.
It was a file.
All right,
three minutes later they call some ticky tack Horse Shit on the Guy.
He's got two files in the first quarter that I sit them down.
I don't fucking Freddy.
Stubhub is fitting that God.
Dude,
what the fuck?
This is the guy that picked the same everybody.
Yo,
yo Yo.
I'm fucking beside myself fucking beside myself going,
this is why
I fucking hate this.
This is why.
This is why these games get fixed.
This is why the NBA is fucking fixed because this is the only sport of the four
major sports that the Goddamn fucking referee can take the best guy out of the
game.
Just give them two quick ones in the first quarter.
Okay.
Can you imagine if you went to go to a football game,
right?
Oh,
Freddy stub hub.
Bob Going to see fucking almost he Todd Brady versus Peyton manning the last
time I go to that fucking Broncos,
fucking patriots play off game and whatever.
Tom Brady gets two quick ones for intentional grounding or some shit and next
thing you know he's standing on the sideline and the fucking backup quarterbacks
in there.
You're just standing there like,
dude,
are you fucking serious?
The guy spent like the whole first half on the bench.
It was brutal and the refs were calling fucking everything teen everybody up.
And I actually,
the only cool part about sitting down low that I saw was at one point is it
Steve Kerr said his first name,
he fucking looks over at Doc rivers and they,
he gives doc rivers.
I like,
dude,
you fucking believe this shit.
And dark looks back.
And I'm like,
yeah,
what the fuck?
Like sharing this moment just as coaches,
like,
what the fuck are these refs doing?
So I don't know what happened at halftime.
If somebody called them up and said,
hey man,
this is like one of the best games of the weekend.
You're fucking this up.
All right,
put your goddamn whistle away.
And the second half they let him play.
And it was,
it was,
it was beautiful.
So fucking amazing game.
Despite the fact all of that shit was going on.
Um,
I know,
I know.
I went on and on,
I probably went on too long.
I understand.
But like,
you know,
it's,
it's such a great game.
And,
uh,
you know,
I kept thinking about Neil always watches all like those fucking,
uh,
you know,
reality shows and stylish shows and all that shit.
And,
uh,
you know,
when they trash people for what they're wearing,
if somebody comes out and they'd be like,
oh,
honey to any accessories,
you need to take a couple of things off it just go out like La,
you know,
they have like,
like too many fucking bracelets and then the fucking,
I dunno,
a hat and a scarf.
Just too many accessories that go.
You just take a couple of things off before you go out into the world,
you know,
be more Parisian,
dopey.
Tampa,
Florida.
Okay.
I don't know why I said Tampa.
I just want to think of no class.
I just think of northern Florida.
Yeah,
I just said that you offended.
Why don't you look out your fucking window past the crocodile over your truck
with the steel balls hanging off the back of,
yeah,
I'm fucking with the Florida.
Come on man.
You can't be all bad if Walt Disney decided to put his world there.
Um,
that's what it feels like.
It,
those basketball games,
they just,
just dial it back a little bit.
Okay.
Could the booty dancers be maybe,
you know,
could they at least be a junior high?
Kids get that happened back.
That could be nice,
you know.
Um,
could you play everybody claps their hands maybe just 18 fucking times during
the game.
You know,
if somebody pays through the fucking nose to get six fucking row,
could I,
could I at least hear the sneakers squeaking?
They don't give a shit.
They don't give a shit what they should've done at the end of the game.
You know,
like,
you know that when you go to the joke shop and you just open the thing up and
all the snakes would come flying out.
That's what they should've done.
There's a whole crowd just given him a fucking facial for fucking tee shirts
and,
you know,
I gotta be honest with you,
even from me,
that was extra conti.
Um,
but once again,
dude,
I always stay to the end of the game.
I don't know why people leave.
And um,
the warriors were up by like fucking 1215 points or something.
I think it was no way they will see 90.
They were by 11.
They're the only like 15 points and then they think they cut it to 11 and people
are leaving because there's only like a minute and a half left.
Everybody was like,
well fuck this gotta beat the traffic,
which is understandable in La.
And everybody starts leaving and I'm psyched because it's getting quiet and I
could finally hear these guys out on the court.
Right?
And um,
so the clip is bring the ball up and they like,
they've taken all the stars are out of the game at this point.
They just got the bench in football teams.
So what the fuck?
Even they're saying this game solver,
clippers bring it up.
They hit a three,
right?
So now it's like a fucking eight point game warriors,
whatever they inbound the ball,
clippers stealing,
run to the three point line.
I love fucking Reggie Miller.
Boom.
Hit another three.
Now it's a five point game.
Now the people left for like,
Oh shit,
the fuck the war is like,
okay,
settle down.
Shut up,
don't get a pass half court.
They get a pass half court fucking clippers.
Steal it again,
boom.
Hit another one.
It's a tool.
Boy gave it
the people who are left to go and fucking crazy.
This is what I wanted.
Now all of a sudden they're fucking putting all the a list as a common backend
to save the fucking day.
Chris Paul's back out there fucking Steph curry,
the whole fucking thing.
The warriors bring the ball back up again.
They somehow lose the ball three toe,
the clip of guys bringing it down.
He jumps up in the air looking for somebody to pass it toe and then she's like,
oh fuck,
there's not enough time yet.
And then launches an attempt that look like they brought me out on the fucking
court and it felt like data way short.
It was just the wrong guy with the ball at the end of the fight.
I don't know who the fuck it was,
but,
uh,
even he looked at me,
she just goes like,
what?
What,
what was that?
I was like,
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
And then that was the end of the game.
And then they were like,
thanks for coming out,
man.
So,
um,
but anyways,
at the end of the day,
I feel like I saw Steph curry.
I got to give it up to the warriors though,
man.
Like just watching the,
watching them,
the way they move with the ball around and all of that.
And even with,
you know,
the Star on the bench,
man,
there was a Thompson,
I don't,
I don't know shit about hope as you can tell Thompson,
that guy was fucking killing them and then they got this other dude,
they're like backup center or something.
This guy is a fucking house.
He looks like a defensive lineman if,
you know,
you put six inches on him and he had one dunk during the game.
I can't believe he didn't fucking Yank the whole rim down.
It was fucking hilarious.
He got a head of steam and everybody just got the fuck out of the way.
Um,
and if only they weren't playing drink during the time when it happened.
Man,
I could actually could have heard that fucking earth shattering dunk who's
literally 30 feet away.
I couldn't even hear it.
All right,
I'm done.
Okay.
I just had to fence.
I'm sorry guys.
I just,
you know,
just had a rough time.
All right.
Let me fucking,
I've been talking so much.
I've gone into screensaver.
Yeah.
I can never remember the fucking password.
You know what it is.
I can't talk and do this at the same time.
These stupid fucking capital letters come on one time.
One time.
And the 52 fucking numbers that come at the end and of course it's wrong.
Why would it be right?
Do I literally have to hit pause?
Okay.
Hang on.
Hang in there with me.
Ah,
when it gets it.
All right,
let's get to,
uh,
let's get to some of the,
the advertising here for this week.
Dude,
that was literally like a 30 minute fucking bitch fest.
I literally should pay for brunch right now.
Thanks for listening guys.
I feel so much better.
All right.
Blue Apron.
You need to know how to cook.
Not only do you feel like you know your way around a kitchen,
but cooking at home means eating healthier and saving money instead of ordering
expensive takeout again.
But where do you say that?
Ah,
blue apron.
As you're covered for less than $10 per meal,
blue apron delivers all the fresh ingredients you need to create home cooked
meals.
Just follow the easy step by step instructions.
Each meal can be prepared in 40 minutes or less.
Everybody clap your hands.
That's what you do.
Have some people come up shooting fucking asparagus at?
Yeah,
a Mac.
So touchable.
No overwhelming tips to the grocery store.
No more sad takeout.
Aw.
No matter your dietary preferences,
Blue Apron makes it a breeze to discover and prepare dishes like I can't read
that shit.
Elsa [inaudible],
spice chicken.
You remember it?
What was that kid show?
T I.
O.
N.
Shawn.
Shawn,
Shawn [inaudible] solution.
Cha Cha,
Cha,
Cha Cha.
Remember that was at the electric company.
They were trying to teach you the how t I o.
N says Shawn.
Sorry.
All right.
[inaudible] spice chicken with braised red cabbage,
smashed potatoes,
abused potatoes,
domestic violence,
potatoes.
No.
Was Shrimp,
tomato,
saffron and all olives.
Short Rib burgers.
Can you say heart disease?
Dude,
he's got disease in his fucking right.
In your own kitchen.
Cook with,
okay.
Yeah.
This just has a bunch of spelling errors,
ingredients that you've never used before,
like watermelon,
radishes and purple potatoes.
Recipes up between 500 to 700 calories.
Proportions.
Calories is spelt wrong,
delicious and good for you.
Right now.
You can get your first two meals for free@blueapron.com slash bird that's blue
apron.com/ [inaudible] I was fucking great.
They,
yeah,
everything.
You learn how to cook a little bit then as not a lot of calories so you stay in
shape watching your fake.
Yeah.
All right.
stamps.com everybody.
All Shit isn't only to regents week.
Thank Christ.
All right.
stamps.com your to do list can seem a little out of control.
I'm flustered so much to do so little time,
but there's one thing you can check off your to do list going to the post
office.
Thanks to stamps.com with stamps.com you can buy and print official US postage.
Not that counterfeit shit official US postage right from your own computer and
printer stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale,
which automatically calculates the exact postage you need for any letter or any
package,
any class of meal.
You'll never waste valuable time going to the post office again,
you'll do it in your own house.
Do everything right now from your own desk with stamps.com print the postage you
need,
put it on your letter or package and then just add it to your mail carrier.
I love how they walk you through the whole process.
Stick it on the package using your right,
our left thumb or possibly your index finger.
Talk the envelope under your arm,
walk towards your mailbox.
Don't forget to open the door before you walk through it and you're done.
I use stamps.com anytime I'm whoring myself out selling posters and that type of
shit.
You know,
anytime I want to go out there and deal with every 11 person having the
sweatiest clammy is fucking hand ever and not having the decency to give me the
fist bump right now.
Use My last name,
birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
which includes the digital scale and up to $55 free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else.
What do I do when I get there?
Click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
ber.
Ah,
thank God that's over.
Thank God it's over.
I don't like it.
I don't like reading out loud.
I'll admit it.
Um,
all right,
let's continue on here with the fucking bitch fest at the is that this podcast
has become this week.
Um,
by the way,
the fucking Boston Bruins,
you know,
madam,
born in game against the predators,
lost two to nothing.
And then we,
uh,
we went down three to one against the Great Dallas Stars team,
one of my favorite fucking teams to watch.
That's the team I'm rooting for out in the West,
even though I still love the Blackhawks and the kings.
And I know what you're thinking.
Hockey fans,
how the fuck can you like the Blackhawks?
And the kinks they'll rivals as cause I'm,
I'm an eastern conference.
I don't give a shit.
I don't give a shit that you guys hate each other or respect both your
franchises.
All right.
Excuse me for liking what you're doing in Baltics.
Um,
by like the Dallas Stars because uh,
I dunno,
I just,
um,
you know that they're the upstarts.
It's always been kings in black cock.
So you got to go for the underdog,
right?
And uh,
yeah,
I don't know.
It's just like watching a play.
So anyways,
what do I feel so defensive right now?
I just enjoy watching him play.
So they go up three to one and my car,
it just sucks.
I'm going to Swatch my team got their ass kicked,
but at least I get to watch.
I get you.
I get to watch this stars.
But uh,
that was it.
And I bet all you fucking cowboy fans watching the hockey.
I'm getting to this man now.
That's four goals in one fucking period.
It's a called a Perry Rod.
Yeah,
I'm enjoying this man.
I'm really enjoying this.
And then that was it.
They got the old right there.
Fred right there.
Fred from fucking the Bro.
It's a little cold lotion.
Few fucking cowboys Bruins went on and scored six unanswered goals.
Brad Mars,
Shannon Marchand,
however the fuck you supposed to pronounce it,
they switched it halfway through.
Um,
scored goal number 29 and 30.
I thought he had 29 goals the other day,
but he's got score scored 29 and 30.
He's never scored 30 goals.
Uh,
let's go,
man,
we haven't had like a big goal score in a long fucking time.
I'm opening scores 50.
Obviously he's not good.
I don't think he's gonna make it to end,
but he's kicked.
He could get 40.
I'm trying to think the last time.
Who was the last Brewen to score 40 goals
since I been getting the,
uh,
you know,
I'm going to look that up right now.
My,
my only guests that I could make would be cam Neely because there was like a
five year period.
I barely watched a Bruins game because I was just,
I barely watch any sports because I was sleeping on a futon and I was rapidly
approaching my mid thirties and I had to get some shit going in my career here.
All right.
Uh,
last Bruin.
Okay.
To score 40 goals.
It's,
do you know something?
It just came up before I even typed that out.
Is this fucking thing listening to me now?
It seems it's so creepy.
All right.
Who's the last farm?
Just prone to score 40 goals in a season.
I'm a say cam.
Neely.
That's the last one.
I remember.
When was the last time the Bruins won the cup?
2011.
We know that.
Who scored the most don't goes.
Why are the Bruins name the Bruins?
The named after a bear.
Oh,
fuck you.
Yeah.
They don't even know.
Sorry.
But the Audi audio there,
they don't even have the fucking
Jerome Miguel [inaudible] the next 40 now list of players have 50 goals.
Boston Bruins.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's not even here.
All right.
Some fucking NHL Nerd.
Yeah.
If you could fucking answer that one for me.
Okay.
Um,
Joe Thornton.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways.
Uh,
all right,
let's get on with the,
let's get on with the questions here.
Oh,
by the way,
fucking Donald Trump.
It's this guy's crushing it.
He just said that he feels it's going to be him.
Hillary Clinton.
Bernie Sanders doesn't have a chance and Hillary will make it unless she gets
indicted.
Dude,
he,
that guy is so fucking brilliant.
He just told everybody that this is what's going to happen.
And the amount of dopes after watching people dive in over each other for free
tee shirts,
they're just going to listen to them and then that's what's going to happen.
And then he fucking throws a little fucking,
uh,
you know,
a little fucking whatever pipe to the knee of Hillary go.
Unless she gets indicted,
which gets that shit storm going again.
We'll Hillary Clinton get invited.
Okay.
I have to tell you,
if those are going to be our two choices,
this is,
it has to be a low point in this country.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
Well,
we have the star of a reality show on one side and then the filthy fucking
Clintons.
Oh my God.
And it's not even Bill Clinton.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
it's just fucking unbelievable.
It's like you're literally,
like I said,
why would you hire the plumber's wife to come over and fix your sink?
I don't understand politics.
I don't get how you can just start at such a high fucking level with no god damn
experience.
Like how did you start as a senator?
You know?
Oh,
that fucking the mayor in New York are Bloomberg.
I got $1 billion yet want to run the city.
Now I get those cars out of the,
I'm going to put some chairs down.
It's like,
who the fuck is this guy?
How come you don't have to start in the mail room?
You know,
you don't have to start off as like an open mic or like a comedian.
Well,
I was married you a prejudiced.
Now I'd like to be senator.
Shut up.
Oh God.
Listen to that fucking voice.
Listen to that voice.
So it looks at that.
Oh,
Donald Trump would have fucking wigwam be a manager.
Shave your head,
you know.
All right.
Two reads for this week.
Oh No,
I already got past this.
Let's get into the,
uh,
let's get into the questions here for this week.
Let's try to fucking calm me down.
Um,
you know what's funny is you to listen to this podcast,
you wouldn't realize what a fucking great mood I'm in a,
I'm actually in a,
I'm in a great mood.
This is what I sound like when I'm in a great mood,
believe it or not.
And I still had a great time at the fucking game.
All right?
Just so you know that.
Okay.
All right,
I'll,
I'll things comedy announcement.
All right.
This is not happening.
Returns to comedy central Tuesday night,
Friday,
uh,
February 23rd at 1230 after midnight.
This season.
Features long form storytelling from all things comics.
Al Madrigal.
Uh,
Christina presents ski and Steve Simone and Philippe Esparza to check that out
on,
uh,
what I say.
February 23rd,
I'll,
that's tomorrow night.
Unless you're listening to this in the future,
then you missed it.
Um,
this is not happening.
All right.
Now this is happening.
I'm reading a question here.
All right.
This guy will just guide.
I don't bunch of Shit,
so I edited the whole thing.
Here's his question.
He says,
I'm 35 years old and still living with my father.
Pathetic.
I know.
Believe me,
it's not by choice.
I've,
I'm finally recovering from lymes disease,
which sucked away 10 years of my life and I will have my student loans paid off
in a couple of months,
months.
What's also sucked away 10 years of my life,
Jesus Christ.
Dude come in with the misery here in a couple of months.
My father is selling the house that we currently live in and moving into a
cheaper fixer upper so he can be mortgage free.
I love that.
It's a great idea provided you know how to fix it up.
MMM.
Speaking of which,
I got all,
all the doors in the last two interior door locks are going to work.
I got a skeleton key for all of them.
I'm so ridiculously excited and for the life of me,
I can't find anyone else who gives a shit.
I've had people over the house and I go,
look at this.
Isn't this great?
And they're like,
yeah,
why would you want to walk doors in your house?
You know,
loved it.
My mother in law,
she came over and she,
she freaked.
She was just like,
oh my God.
She goes,
that is so cool.
She totally got it.
Did that,
that made it worth it right there.
So anyways,
let me,
uh,
let me continue on.
Um,
he goes,
so anyways,
he had paid off his student loans.
He goes,
I can,
so my head,
here's the choice I have to make.
I can either live with my dad even longer than I already have and be rent free
in this fixer upper so that I can save up money and get my own place.
Or I can rent a shitty apartment and burned a grand a month,
which would clearly be better spent on a new house if I was in my twenties or
early thirties.
I might be a little more open to the idea of renting one,
which I did in college.
The upside of renting an apartment is having a little more confidence and
integrity when I'm out on a date,
knowing that we can retreat back to my own place,
a set of my parents' house.
We'll do.
Why don't you just hit him with the Lyme disease fucking story,
you know,
and just tell him,
yeah,
I'm living at home cause I'm not dropping a grant.
I'm going to be buying a house as long as long as you have a game plan,
women will fucking dealt.
They'll,
they'll ride it,
they'll write it out with you for a little bit,
feel saying,
listen,
yeah.
I had Lyme disease for 10 fucking years and,
uh,
I finally got over it and I had to move back in with my dad and that's brutal
right there.
Had moving back in with my dead.
You almost want to have that part of a whole nother,
you know,
run on sentence.
You just got to plow right through.
That had moved back home,
my dad.
But,
um,
I'm on the fuck.
Do you gotta see you gotta say I moved back home with my dad,
but I,
I almost have enough money for a down payment on a house,
so I'm not throwing a thousand off Jesus Christ bats.
I'll tell you it's a rough one.
You know?
Um,
uh,
you know what?
Fuck these fucking fuck them.
Fuck them.
Just tell them what you're doing.
Yeah.
Living at home because I'm saving up to buy a house.
I am 35.
Just own it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Listen,
I have my own entrance into the house.
My Dad wants to
anyways,
just plow ahead.
If I was in my twenties,
early thirties,
I might be a little more open to the idea of renting,
which I did college.
Sorry.
I already read that.
The upside of renting and apartment is having a little more,
AH,
Jesus Christ.
Bill.
MMM.
All right.
It's also the freedom of coming home to a quiet house and knowing that my God
damn food will still be in the refrigerator when I get home.
My brother is also still living at home.
He suffers from migraines.
Um,
dude,
what the fuck?
Where do you,
what do you live near?
What's sort of fucking,
this sounds like one of those fucking movies where they have
you guys eaten the lead,
paint your house,
like,
what's going on here?
So you get Lyme disease.
Where are you going to fucking hike?
Not wearing any shoes and get bit by a tick.
I can't remember.
There's too many fucking diseases.
Anyways,
he goes,
so should I get on with my life and start pissing money away on rent or should I
stick it out a little longer and continue to live with,
with father so I can get my own fixer upper?
I love the podcast.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself in the Aa with a d Jay Kay.
Um,
all right.
I would,
uh,
look,
if you just have to stick it out a little longer,
who gives a fuck at this point?
You already did 10 years.
You know,
if,
if you can get yourself in a situation where you can actually own the place
where you're living.
MMM.
[inaudible] say that you're basically,
you,
instead of having a landlord,
the banks,
your landlord,
you have a mortgage.
And people said,
you ran a d,
you own I own,
I own a house.
We bought a house.
Oh yeah.
Outright.
No,
no,
we'll make it mortgage payment.
All right then you don't own it.
Somebody owns you.
Right.
That's what happened.
You used to be,
you'll use,
do you use to be in a situation where somebody owns you month to month,
but any point you could just take off,
you could leave the plantation.
Okay.
Now you just signed up for 30 years.
Somebody fucking putting it in.
Yeah.
Every fucking month.
So what I would say is I would stick it out a little bit longer with my dad and
uh,
I would buy a house where,
you know,
it's not one of those deals where you could just make the mortgage payment.
You got to get into a situation where not only do you,
you're making the mortgage payment,
but you can throw something at the principal.
You know,
you got to beat the fuck out of that and you got to beat the fuck out of it
quick because they front end load all the interests,
which to this day,
I don't know why it's legal.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
The president only makes 400 grand a year that,
oh,
I forgot.
That's right.
Yeah,
and bankers go out and have like $400,000 fucking,
you know,
I wouldn't even say Christmas parties.
I mean that's what they probably play the outfield to come and play their
daughter's 16th birthday.
I said there's no way they taste them.
400 grant.
Green Day.
You could get green day for 400 grand.
Right.
Play a half hour in your backyard.
That's then what's it?
That's a tree off.
It's a 120 $533,000 each hour in a 34 for the lead singer because he sees
playing all the guitar parts and singing.
All right.
Yeah.
I'm going to do a startup.
I Want Green Day to pay my play.
My 48th birthday.
All right.
UK,
United Kingdom.
Dear Bill,
when are you coming back to the U K and are you watching any football,
parentheses soccer in between Bruins games?
Nah,
I've been just,
I've been really fucking busy so I haven't gotten to watch any of that.
Uh,
I saw a little bit the other day.
I don't know,
it was in some pub.
I always watch it,
man,
when I see,
you know,
if I got,
if I stumble upon it I will watch it.
But,
um,
I'm hoping to do a European tour,
towards the end of the summer.
Maybe like in August.
It'd be really interesting to go through Scandinavia,
you know,
when the sun's not going down at three and three in the afternoon,
which to be honest with you,
I actually think it's pretty fucking cool,
you know?
Um,
I got to admit,
when I went to Iceland in December,
that's the fucking time to go.
Don't go in the summertime when every jerk off is there.
You go in the summertime when nobody wants to go,
and then you go to that blue lagoon fucking spa.
It's just naturally,
he did buy the fucking volcanoes or whatever the fuck it is.
It's,
it's an incredible fucking incredible,
one of the,
uh,
when the coolest places I've ever been to.
Um,
but yeah,
I'm definitely going to be coming back doing a big standup tour and I'm going to
be adding some,
uh,
eastern European countries.
Um,
and I'm really excited about that.
A buddy of mine just went to Germany,
was saying what a great time they had and he was actually in a bar and,
uh,
met somebody that knew what my stuff was or something.
He would do some of my standup jokes or something.
So I'm mostly German,
so I would be excited to,
uh,
to go back to the,
to the motherland there.
Um,
speaking of which actually watched this documentary,
my wife tape was talking to that,
the charisma of Adolf Hitler on PBS.
And it was this fascinating thing how they talked about just what is charisma.
Yeah.
You know,
and they had this whole thing was saying how like Hitler could not had just no
functioning relationships with anybody one on one,
but he just crushed it in front of a crowd and how he would make them wait and
all of that shit is fucking hilarious.
Like he's waiting to start a speech.
Everyone's cheering and he's just standing there until they're dead silent.
You know,
it reminded me one time,
Nia took,
I took me to go see Erika Badu and she comes out and everyone wants you to sing
and she spends the first five minutes just walking around the lighting,
the incense.
So I'm watching Hitler's,
she's got,
she got this from Hitler to the fucking thing.
Everybody's like,
oh,
we need to behave ourselves.
And then the performance will begin.
But they had all these creepy fucking speeches.
Yeah.
That he was getting,
he was doing this thing where he was going.
There's a group of people among us
who
can basically live anywhere.
They do business anywhere.
It doesn't matter them to them.
They live in Paris next month they'll live,
they'll live in fucking Vienna.
Then they'll live here.
And Blah,
blah,
blah with no ties to that hole.
And he just keeps spoonfeeding them.
Do you know,
he won't come out and say it,
this group of people because they have no attachment to Germany.
Okay.
You know,
but blah,
blah blah blah.
Then finally sent me,
the crowd goes,
Joe yelled out Jews and it learned,
never addressed it and then just kept going.
It was are you have to see this.
It is the creepiest,
okay.
Absolutely.
Absolutely creepy is fucking thing I've ever seen in my life.
And then,
uh,
but I would,
I would be lying to you if I didn't tell you that I learned some things as far
as performance in front of a crowd.
I mean,
you've got to give it up.
The guy was a beast.
I don't,
I don't even remotely agree with the guys message,
but Jesus Christ,
okay.
The guys going out in front of a crowd,
you know,
a Kevin Hart size fucking crowd and doesn't say a fucking word he doesn't get to
do is the exact opposite of the clippers game Max.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
Hitler's got to come back and start running the NBA there.
I said it,
they can just get past the fact that 99% of the players are African American.
I think he could do some great things for the league.
I think he quiet it down.
Alright,
sorry.
Anyways,
so I will be going to the eastern Europe.
That's what I was trying to say.
Or Europe in general.
Do you,
okay.
There we go.
All right.
Apple fives.
The FBI.
Dear big brother Billy,
what are your thoughts in the battle between apple and the FBI regarding hacking
into the,
the phones of the San Bernardino terrorist?
Also,
just the fact that the FBI has the phones for two months and can't get into
them,
put a dent into any government overreach conspiracy theories.
Uh,
no.
He says the situation with the apple is FBI wants to apple to create an
operating system that would allow for them to hack encryption on the phone.
Uh,
they would upload the system to the terrorist's phone to allow them to unlock
it.
However,
yeah.
What they would upload this system to the terrorist's phone to allow them to
unlock it.
However,
if apple does this,
the operating system can be used by the FBI and others to totally compromise any
security on any iPhone in the future.
How the solution is simple.
It's just like,
just bring the phones to us and we'll hack into it.
And whatever information needed on the fonts will do that for you.
Yeah.
Once again,
because of these terrorists con,
what you're gonna do is you're going to allow all the,
you know,
these fucking lunatics at the top to take even more power and privacy away from
you.
And I could just,
yeah.
Simplest way to tell you this is just like,
you know,
the,
the amount of people out there that can actually handle power is very,
it's very rare.
I mean,
look in my business,
okay?
You see what happens?
You know,
everybody's down to earth,
everybody's cool,
and all of a sudden you get your own Sitcom and next thing you know,
you're banning people from the set your tip and shit over.
And nobody's saying shit because you make it all this fucking money.
You don't handle it well.
Right.
Be like
being like in at the top levels of government and security.
It's the same fucking thing.
I don't think they handled it well.
I think it's way too much freedom and I'm sick of people saying shit like,
hey man,
if you're not doing anything,
then what are you worried about?
I'm worried about the fact that,
you know,
just,
okay,
well she would being stupid.
We're awful.
We're fucking terrible people.
What terrible with the amount of access that we have now,
you don't need to give people more access and I don't feel like,
you know,
they keep just hiding behind this whole fucking thing of like,
you know what?
We're just going to use it for the bad people.
It's like,
yeah,
but you get to decide who the fuck's bed.
That Snowden guy,
he had to walk away what they were building.
It was like the fucking Batman movie.
The spire on their own fucking people.
They're lunatics.
I don't know what they do.
I always picture him just sitting there fucking,
I don't know.
I would do Gino,
like that Snowden guy.
He says when he stays in a fucking hotel room,
he unplugs the phone because they had that speaker phone.
Do you know that down at the front desk they can turn it on and just listen to
whatever you're doing in there.
Do you know fucking your way talking to yourself,
Robin one out.
Okay.
Whatever the fuck you doing in the privacy,
your own fucking hotel,
they can just listen in on that shit.
It's fucking,
it's just the whole thing is creepy and um,
okay.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
I can't imagine,
you know what,
by the time,
you know,
if I live,
to be like 90 a hundred years old,
like I would like to,
um,
I want to see the fucking,
I want to live in every fucking decade,
you know,
I want to get to the 60s again.
I was born in 1960.
I don't want to make it,
you know,
I just keep thinking shit like that.
I want to make it right.
So,
um,
I can't imagine like the lack of privacy that there'll be if you live that long
just with like people with like drones and shit like that,
like the cameras and just how like I think in the future,
right,
they're going to make these,
I'd have like these,
uh,
like microchips like Mres,
you know?
Okay.
And like somebody walks by and somebody just hits you with a little mist and all
these little microchips go on and when you shower,
like most of them come off,
but like a fuels still stick on you and then your next door neighbor could just
watch your whole fucking life.
There'll be no more TV shows.
We'll just be spying on each other.
I don't know.
I think it's all fucking creepy and I think that's way too much.
I don't think the FBI needs to fucking do that.
I think apple should work with the FBI and uh,
if there's ever like somebody that they want to fucking check in on,
you know,
let them do it.
So have them call them up.
Yeah.
Um,
hang on one second.
Okay.
Hey,
I'm finishing up my podcasts.
Let me call you back in five minutes.
All right?
Yup.
Cool.
Um,
all right.
Let's get onto the next one.
All right.
Gay Friend.
Hey Bill.
First off,
thanks for the laughs.
Well,
you're welcome.
I'm 30 years old and decided to go back to school two years ago to study
chemistry.
I'm an idiot like you,
but with enough effort,
anything is possible.
Yeah.
I believe Kevin Garnett said that.
Um,
during my first semester back,
I befriended a gay guy.
I am not gay myself,
nor am I homophobic.
I've also never had a gay friend.
We have a lot in common except for the fact that he likes to give and take it up
the ass.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you could've said,
except that he likes gay sex.
All right.
I don't proofread these.
I just stumbled on the sentences.
Here we go.
During that first semester,
I just started to get the feeling that he liked me.
Uh,
I started to get uncomfortable studying with him and stopped answering his phone
calls for a few days.
After those two days,
I decided to call him,
explain my concerns.
I told him that I've never had a gay friend before.
I think he's a cool guy,
but I also explained that I'm getting the feeling that he thinks he might have a
chance.
Do that.
You handled it perfectly.
He goes,
he laughed and he assured me that he wasn't hitting on me and knew I wasn't gay.
He also told me that if he feel he cray iffy,
if I feel he crosses a line to tell him,
tell him,
okay,
great.
I said,
I dunno dude.
He said he wasn't hitting on you and then he's kind of like,
yeah,
but if I cross a line,
okay,
I,
the way I look at it,
at the end of the day,
it's a guy,
all right,
and guys think,
you know,
if you're talking to them,
you want to hook up,
right.
That's why women,
you know when they walk down the street guys are like,
smile,
say hello.
It's like I can't,
or else you think I want to fuck you and then I got to deal with that level of
interaction.
That's why I got to walk down the street with this Donald Trump.
Look on my face.
Right.
The same thing I always feel,
I feel I would like gay guy.
She can't be,
can't be,
can only be so fucking nice or are they going to think they got a shot?
He,
cause they're,
they were born with a deck.
That's what I taught.
I did a bit about that.
Your Dick's a,
you're dick believes man.
It's fucking wave and everybody around the third base.
All right.
Now I'm in my second year of school,
fourth semester and we have more of the same classes but not together over the
winter break.
He called me and asked if I wanted to go to the bar with him and some other
friends from school.
I happily said yes and drove to the bar.
After about two hours.
He asked me if I have any weed and if I'd smoke,
smoke him down.
Are we still talking about weed here?
What are we doing here?
I said sure,
let's go to my truck and smoke a bowl during this drunk and stoners session.
He proceeds to get wet.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Can you got to hear that?
So yeah,
listen to it.
You know what your gut was,
right?
You called them on the shit and he said that he wasn't,
and I knew it with that fucking line,
but if I ever crossed the line,
let me know that he was trying to wear you down.
He was trying to hang in there long enough that you finally just said,
you know what?
Fuck it.
Uh,
so basically,
okay.
He proceeds to get worried.
He goes basically telling me that he knows I'm not gay,
but I'm the kind of guy he likes and I'm one of his best friends and I was life
sucks because he's gay.
I just started laughing and saying,
what the fuck?
I'm too nice of a guy
to say get the fuck away from me.
So I let him finish his thoughts.
He was drunk and being emotional too,
which was annoying.
He reminded me of my ex girlfriend.
I'm just glad he didn't start crying.
Anyway,
after what af after he was done,
I said,
that's great,
but I'm not wired that way.
Sorry.
He kept going on and on asking me if I'm sure there isn't any secret hidden,
desired buried deep within me.
Uh,
yeah,
dude,
it's,
it's late night.
It's late at night.
This guy,
he's going all in.
Uh,
I explained to him that if I was doing the same thing to a girl that I had a
crush on,
I would be considered a creep and that the girl wouldn't want to hang out with
me anymore.
Dude,
why are you writing me,
man?
You've got all your handling all of this perfectly.
Um,
I already failed because the second he got weird and my truck,
I would be like,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
this was about two months ago and I've ignored him since.
He called me three times and I ignored them.
Two of the calls were in the middle of the night.
Oh,
Jesus.
One 30 at 2:30 AM,
which leads me to believe he was being drunk and emotional.
Exactly.
He goes,
just like a 23 year old girl.
I don't see him at school anymore because I avoid him on purpose.
My question to you is,
am I doing the right thing?
Yeah,
you're totally doing the right thing.
It's just cause you had get both guys and that because he's gay and he's all
like basically in the media,
they're always considered victims.
If there's any sort of soul,
like you gotta be more accepting.
You know,
at some point if somebody is making you fucking uncomfortable and you fucking
address and they still crossed the line,
if that's something you're not comfortable with it yet,
fuck off silver beet it,
you fucking creeping me out,
you know?
Anyways,
he goes,
my question to you is,
am I doing the right thing?
I've never gone out of my way to avoid someone like this except for a girl.
After I break up with them,
I have no desire to hang out with them anymore.
It's not that big of a deal.
It's not like a work friend you hang out with,
but then one of you gets a different job and the two of you stop hanging out.
I do feel bad though because he has had a hard life.
He's the classic Gay Guy.
I grew up in Texas and was harassed.
The end is hated by his dad.
It sucks,
but it's not my problem.
I used to listen to his problems and try to give him advice on life and
happiness and be a good friend.
But after that whole truck and his incident,
I don't want to do that anymore.
Thanks for the help.
Hope you and the lovely new year.
Have a great day.
Yeah.
No Dude,
you're fucking,
you handled it perfectly.
You would never a jerk to the guy.
You told them exactly how you were feeling at the end of the day.
You had respect for yourself and your own boundaries,
which he didn't sell.
Fuck off,
you know?
Yeah.
Teach Amelia teachable lesson fix time.
He has a straight friend,
you know,
just be,
be a friend.
Don't get high.
Go into his truck and tried to fuck them.
Yeah.
It's pretty straight forward.
Alright.
Germaphobe bill though.
I can't,
I don't know leukocyte.
What the fuck does that,
where I gotta look that word up.
Said some fucking spaceship.
Is that a,
uh,
I don't know what that means.
I,
I feel like half the podcast is laughing at me and the other half is pretending,
pretending like they know what the fuck it means.
Okay.
Leukocytes,
a collarless cell
that circulates in the blood and bodily fluids in is involved in counteracting
foreign substances and diseases and so I'm a white self though that you didn't
realize how fucking original that is.
Oh,
by said the word right.
Jesus Christ.
That was fucking brilliant.
My Hat's off to you and also ties in with Germaphobe.
Okay.
You know whenever you get sick you white cell count goes up.
Do you realize how many fucking levels said installed is working?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Tip of the hat to you.
All right.
A few days ago I was stretching in the gym with the girl I was dating.
She picked up her phone from a bench,
looked at the screen and said,
God,
by screen is so dirty.
And then proceeded to use your tongue to lick the phone screen and wipe it off
with their sleeve.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Jay,
just when you thought getting high with your gay friend and he goes for your
deck and your truck was the fucking weirdest,
almost uncomfortable thing,
you were going to Jesus.
He goes,
I dry heave,
and she got mad at me claiming that she was a medical student and done things
like that.
Doing things like that was good for my immune system.
Yeah.
Fucking Med students always got to tell you they are med students.
He goes,
I couldn't get over it.
I had to get away from her.
Now it's in my psyche that maybe I am a Germaphobe.
When I use an ATM or Debit Card,
Pin pad,
I always have to wash my hand touching those things.
Grosses me out.
Am I a Germaphobe ps?
How many hands do you shake a day?
MMM,
no,
dude,
you're girlfriend is a med student,
but she's also gross.
That's fucking disgusting.
This fucking disgusting period.
Okay.
There's so many other ways where you can just go into the fucking gym is enough
to keep your immune system up.
You don't need the lick your phone.
You fucking pig.
Disgusting.
That's fucking gross.
All right.
End of story.
No,
you're not a Germaphobe.
You're an intelligent human being.
That's an,
you know,
you just aware.
Yeah.
I don't like touching those fucking things.
When I go to the airport,
I got it.
I got to get on that little shuttle bus thing and they're like,
hold on before the fucking thing starts.
I always pulled down the sleeve of my jacket and I hold onto it like that.
Yeah.
I don't need fecal matter in mucus and Tj's and God knows what else is fucking
on that day.
Alright.
Gross.
You're not a Germaphobe.
All right.
How many hands do I shake a day?
Uh,
I don't know.
Sometimes zero.
Sometimes a if I do wish,
I don't,
I don't fucking know.
I,
I know,
but I go and I wash my hands afterwards and I don't touch my face after I do it
because I'm afraid I'm going to get pink eye.
But a,
I don't shake a lot of hats.
MMM.
But I will say people love coming out of the bathroom and they'd be like,
hey,
Belle.
And then shaking your hands.
I,
I really got to in the moment get better and be like,
dude,
not you just came up.
Give me the elbow dude.
You just came out of the bathroom.
I don't know you.
I don't know if you're good at washing your hands.
I want to know you like that.
Alright.
Dilemma.
Hey Bill,
I'll,
that reminds me a long time ago,
I worked the Improv in Dallas and I pissed off this fucking,
oh,
I think I pissed off this older texts and guy,
or maybe this was this weird idea of humor.
He came up and shook my hand right at the end of the show.
I said,
hey man,
thanks for coming out.
And he just goes,
I just paid
okay.
That was high.
Oh,
you know,
I'm not gonna do anything with my hand.
My hand is that you could have your urine on it.
It's fine.
I'm not going to eat.
I'm just going to shake a bunch of other hands now and they're going to have you
pee on it and then I'm going to wash my hands and it's going to be off.
You know what I mean?
You don't think you got,
you just went into the bathroom,
you know,
have any idea what's on your fucking hands?
Um,
that's now on my hands.
Yeah,
we're all filthy.
Alright.
Dilemma.
Hey Bill.
Uh,
so I'm in a bit of a tight situation.
Me and some were playing to take on taking a weekend trip down to Austin to
attend a music festival.
My ladies,
grandma is getting married the same week,
the same weekend as the concert.
Obviously I have to pick.
Okay.
Bye Ladies.
Grandma is getting married the same weekend as the concert.
Obviously I have to pick which event.
I'm going to a 10.
Your girlfriend's grandma is getting married,
but when the fuck did grandma have her mother when she was like 12?
My girl,
there's no choice here.
This isn't a dilemma.
This is like an obvious,
he goes,
my girl left a completely up to me with no hard feelings attached,
at least from her.
I'm afraid of upsetting her family by not going to the wedding.
Fuck that.
Go to the fucking wedding.
Look,
if you're going to marry this girl,
you have to establish early that you're not going to every stupid fucking
function you have to do that.
He goes,
but I should mention that my,
uh,
my girls,
grandma doesn't really care much for me or so it seems she tells my girlfriend
that she should explore her options a bit while she's still young also.
And I also have not been formally slash officially invited.
My girlfriend and I had been dating for two years,
so it's not like I'm a new boyfriend or anything.
What should I do?
I'd love to hear the lovely knee is take as well.
If she's around.
Unfortunately she's not around.
Um,
yeah,
dude.
Fuck that.
You go down with your friends and you go to the concert and you have a great
fucking time.
Okay.
And if this woman doesn't like you,
at the end of the day,
she's going to die soon.
So who gives a fuck?
Okay.
It gives a shit.
Sound like her mom doesn't like it,
then that's a problem because she's going to be around and you're going to have
kids and she's going to fucking show up and it's going to be a big fucking pain
in the ass grammar.
It gives a fuck.
Right.
Should explore her options as she's still running around single and her fucking
eighties you know,
she's just projecting our own regret of that fucking
oxen driver.
She married back in the 1920s whatever the fuck she did.
Yeah,
go to the concert.
It's not a dilemma to go to the concert.
Okay.
Just tell your girlfriend.
So you know what?
I decided I'm going to go to the concert and have a good time at the wedding and
just fucking leave it at that.
And if she gives you a rough time about it,
don't bring up the fact that your grant or grandma doesn't like you and blah,
blah blah,
because then she's going to try and fix it now.
You guys just need to spend more time together.
Just tell her.
I would just,
I would rather go to the concert.
Yeah.
Yes.
And just leave it at dead.
If she gives you a ton of shit,
just be like,
listen,
you know,
five buddies,
you do some,
but you also had plans to go to a concert and he chose to do that.
I,
I wouldn't give you a rough time about it.
I would want you to do what was going to make you happy.
I would appreciate it if you extend me the same courtesy.
Yeah,
I see it now.
I was going to say,
you fucking sound so and so don't,
don't,
don't do the last part.
All right.
That's what I would do.
Okay.
There you go.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody be by de your heads.
Um,
thank you for listening and thank you everybody.
That's uh,
you know,
coming out to the shows this weekend at Foxwoods,
um,
you know,
I have some people were talking about,
the ticket prices and everything.
I can't control that people go on and buy some of these fucking scalping ticket
things,
you know,
the stubhub peoples of the fucking world.
So I got to figure something out with that.
I Know Louis C K does something where he sells tickets,
you know,
on his own website.
But my thing is like,
well then how do you stop them from just going to your website and buying up a
bunch of tickets and sending the fucking price through the roof?
Like how do you do that?
Cause I don't want you guys getting fucked over.
Um,
but I can't tell you this.
If you do go and you do pay through the nose,
there won't be anybody screaming and yelling and shooting fucking tee shirts at
you while I'm doing my Dick and shit jokes.
All right?
Okay,
that's a podcasts.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check in on Thursday.